machine learning is one of the fastest
growing fields today data scientists use
machine learning to predict the future
enabling them to forecast sales
understand user behavior and identify
potential market segments companies
crave machine learning products and
there's an ever-increasing demand for
engineers and data scientists who are
able to deploy machine learning models
for a global audience in the intro to
machine learning nano degree program
you'll learn foundational machine
learning algorithms starting with
cleaning data and building supervised
learning models you'll then move on to
exploring deep learning and unsupervised
learning at each step you'll gain
practical experience by applying your
skills to code exercises and projects if
you have experience in Python but
haven't yet studied machine learning the
intro to machine learning nano degree
program is a killer intro to a
fascinating world to support your
learning journey you'll have access to a
dedicated mentor and career services
you'll also complete portfolio ready
real-world projects I highly recommend
you to start machining today you will
find your dream job but most of all even
a fascinating new skill or the makeup is
really smart are you ready to take your
first steps in machine learning to learn
how to make machine learning products at
scale are you ready to deploy machine
learning to predict the future
enroll in the intro to machine learning
nano degree program today